[موسيقى]
واحة المجاري في صحراء مصر الغربية
هي التعريف التام للعزلة الكاملة
عن بعد ، وهي مكان ذو جمال طبيعي لا يُنسى ،
هذه واحدة من أفضل تجارب حياتي
[موسيقى]
في العصور القديمة ألكسندر العظيم
أتى إلى هنا ل  استشر أوراكل شهير
من أمون
اليوم يجذب السياح
الوعد بالاسترخاء
وتجديد الشباب تقدم سيوة العديد
من أنواع الأنشطة الصحية رقم واحد ،
فالرمال عندما دفننا تحت
الرمال ، وهذا يزيل كل
الرطوبة ويساعد كثيرًا على
المفاصل والعظام ، لذا فهي جيدة جدًا للدورة
الدموية ، لذلك هذا هو المعبد
عمر كامزا يدير أدوات العافية في سيوة وحولها ،
يأتي العديد من ضيوفه خصيصًا
للعلاجات الرملية
ولكن بعد ذلك يجدون أن الواحة لديها الكثير
لتقدمه في  ملح الاكتئاب الصحراوي
وفير في المجاري
بينما يجعل من المستحيل
شرب الماء واستخدامه في الزراعة ،
فمن المفترض أن يستخدم
الملح في العلاج.  الفوائد ، إنه
جيد جدًا للجروح ،
الملح جيد جدًا للرئتين لجميع أجهزة
التنفس في الجسم ،
لقد أتت فيتوريا جانيتازيو لرؤيتها
مع أسرتها
لمدة أسبوع من الاسترخاء والعلاج الصحي من
المستحيل أن تذهب تحت الماء يمكنك أن
تطفو
كما هو الحال في بحيرة سحرية
[موسيقى]
توجد ينابيع مياه عذبة في المجاري
أيضًا
هذه بقع صافية حيث
يُعتقد أن الملكة المصرية تسبح
[موسيقى]
بشكل طبيعي المياه التي تخرج من
تحت الأرض
إنها جيدة جدًا للجسم  الجلد
والمفاصل والشعر له فوائد مختلفة
لصحة الجسم ، تعرف على الواحة التي هي بالتأكيد
وجهة بعيدة عن المسار المطروق
ولكن إغراء المنتجعات الصحية
والعلاجات
تغري السائحين بالسير في الطريق الأقل
[موسيقى]